hey guys we've got a huge problem in the
church today
a lot of people are listening to
preachers who preach to itching ears
who allow it to happen who listen to
motivational messages that's just
puffing up the self life but Jesus calls
us to deny ourselves to pick up our
cross and follow Jesus I want to read a
quote to you from my book bold Pursuit
there's a big problem in the church
today a problem of lukewarm men who care
more about living for the things of this
world than about living for the God of
this world
you cannot serve Christ with only your
heart or only your mind you need both in
other words you need to follow Christ
with the right Doctrine and devotion you
need to follow Christ the way he wants
you to follow him
not following him from the self-life you
need to deny yourself pick up your cross
and follow Jesus if you truly love him
I'll see in the next video bye